I used to be so scared when I was a kid
still I'm I didn't sleep through the
night until I was 13. whoops admitted it
would call my parents in a room every
one time tried to sleep over Chris
Siegel's house couldn't do it had to go
to the bathroom wouldn't go to the
bathroom because I was too scared woke
up in the middle of night with a log of
[__] halfway coming out of my ass whoops
admitted it still think about
skinnamarinks ah so um so um the other
day I've been like putting into bed and
he would be like will you left me for a
bit and I'll say buddy I'm not gonna do
that because you need to go to bed
because I think you can do it you're a
big boy right can you at least try and
they'll say okay and then he'll say can
you leave the door open for a bit I
don't want to be like hey are you scared
because then I don't want to introduce
that thought into his mind in case he's
not scared he's just like doesn't want
to go to sleep and he's crying because
he doesn't want to go to sleep so
finally I was like buddy so what is the
deal why do you not want to go to bed uh
lately what's going on and he was like
oh I don't know you leave the door a
little bit open I said is it is it maybe
that you're like scared or something and
he and he says yes I said are you scared
and he said yes I said of what and he
said spiders in my room and I said oh
buddy well you don't have to worry about
spiders spiders first of all there's no
spiders in your room second of all
spiders are our friends they eat other
insects that are like you know Annoying
and stuff and he said really I said yeah
so you're scared of spiders and he said
yeah and I said oh well you don't have
to be and he said can we get one
tomorrow
I said you want to get a pet spider he
said yes so now here's the deal
I'm
terrified of spiders
okay I gotta get a [__] spider now
because my son wants a pepper he won't
stop talking about it can we get a pet
spider so now oh he turned it on its ass
no it's me who's scared
now I'm scared of spiders whoops I
admitted it
but I am dude and I kept that close to
the chest in case like I don't want fans
coming up to me being like here look
here look right here look at the spider
look the way they hold it here look here
he is oh there he is there he is in
their mouth
so now I gotta get a hairy you know what
I mean
we're not getting a spider but he wants
a spider and I've [__] up by asking
him if he was scared so now I'm
confronted with my scariness
and that and that's what it's like being
a father dude
[Music]
crazy
crazy crazy congratulations